the Trump administration pledges to
Stonewall Congress Hillary Clinton
signals some interest in 2020 and the
Turks begin their attack on the Kurds
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored
by expressvpn protect your online
privacy today at expressvpn dot-com /
Ben okay we've got a ton to get to today
you know I take off 25 hours guys just
to do some atoning just to get right
with God and the world explodes because
that's the way things work okay so the
latest in impeachment cake 23:19 over
the past 25 36 hours basically the White
House has now pledged they're gonna
Stonewall Congress this is not a good
strategy it's not now I know there are a
lot of folks on the right who are
cheering this a lot of folks on the
conservative side who are saying this is
exactly what the White House should be
doing given the political nature of this
impeachment inquiry and there is truth
to the fact that the White House should
be pushing back on some of these
subpoenas that the White House should be
pushing back on Congress's power to do
some of the stuff that they are doing
however to simply state that they are
going to in blanket fashion sort of
Stonewall Congress is a mistake the
reason it's a mistake is because it goes
one of a couple of ways one all of this
goes to the courts and the courts
actually rule against the Trump
administration in which case they have
to turn over all of this stuff anyway
and now there is impetus for an
impeachment move because of so-called
obstruction because the White House is
attempting to prevent information from
being disseminated and obstruction was
used as an impeachment grounds from both
Clinton and Nixon so that's possibility
number one possibility number two it
goes to the courts and the court simply
declined to answer the question they say
this falls under what they call the
political question doctrine meaning that
when the branches are hashing things out
between themselves it is really not the
business of the judiciary to step in and
do anything about it
well that then throws it back on
Congress and Congress in order to defend
its own prerogatives to get information
because Congress does have the
constitutional power to impeach Congress
does have the constitutional power to
investigate under article 1 and article
2 of the Constitution with all of that
said Congress will then be led to get
it's sort of spine up a little bit get
its back up and say to the executive
branch listen even if we're Republicans
we are not gonna let the executive
branch simply decline to work with
Congress in any way
in any investigation because that sets a
precedent that is undoable once a
Democrat is in office again and then
possibility number three is at the white
house stone walls and gets away with it
the problem there is that once that
strategy is on the table and has been
successfully used it is now used by
presumably every president and that
means that the presidency no matter
which party the presidency is in is
being held by the president can now get
away with anything okay so with that
said the White House's basic statement
which is the Congress needs to be
specific about what exactly it is
calling for what Congress is actually
doing legally speaking that part is true
but the White House basically saying
we're not cooperating under nearly any
circumstances it depends how you read
the White House's letter but if that is
what they are actually claiming that's a
massive overreach and it's bad move
strategically it's gonna be much easier
to show that the White House is
stonewalling and therefore engaged in a
cover-up then to show that the White
House actually involved itself in
criminally impeachable behavior in the
first place as I've been saying for a
couple of weeks now it is always easier
to get a precedent for a cover-up than
it is to get a precedent for a crime it
was easier to get Richard Nixon for the
cover-up of Watergate than it was to get
Richard Nixon for Watergate itself it
was easier to get President Clinton for
obstruction of justice than it was to
get President Clinton for any of the
underlying crimes including perjury by
the way and so the Trump White House
should just take note of that fact when
they decide how far to stonewall
Congress can we're gonna get to exactly
what the White House did are they
actually stonewalling Congress or are
they actually now we'll get to that in
just one second first let's talk about
health insurance health insurance helps
with medical bills but it does not
actually replace your lost income this
is where you have a disability insurance
disability insurance it does replace
your lost income it's essentially
insurance for your income it protects
that paycheck if you get sidelined by an
illness or an injury so where can you
get disability insurance without
spending a fortune and without spending
a long time figuring out the right place
to do it you go over to policy
genius.com
policy genius does all the shopping for
you the compare quotes from the top
disability insurance companies to find
the best price for you then they're
licensed experts manage the application
process to save you time and hassle and
policy genius doesn't just make
disability insurance easy they can also
help you find the right life insurance
and home and auto insurance - they're
your one-stop shop for insurance so if
you rely on your income to get by head
on over to policy genius
to compare disability insurance quotes
today it's an important adult thing to
do insurance is you hedging against the
possibility of bad things happening and
if you're adult you need to think about
that stuff particularly if you have a
family that you are taken care of policy
genius will help you protect your
paycheck at a price that makes sense for
you policy genius the easy way to
compare and buy disability insurance and
life insurance and all sorts of
insurance go check them out of policy
genius com ok so here is the actual
story according to the Washington Post
the White House on Tuesday said it would
not cooperate with the houses
impeachment inquiry of President Trump
arguing that the probe quote violates
the Constitution the rule of law and
every past precedent in an escalating
standoff with an unbound Congress in a
scathing a page letter the White House
said the inquiry into the Ukraine
scandal was without merit complained
that the president has been denied his
due process rights and argued the
Democrats were intent on overturning the
results of the 2016 election and
influencing at the 2020 contest okay so
as I say there are a couple of angles to
this letter one to go through the letter
today what angle number one the
political angle obviously the Trump
administration trying to make the case
this entire thing is politically
illegitimate now does that make it
constitutionally illegitimate of course
not the house has the unilateral power
of impeachment it does not make it
constitutionally ridiculous for the
house to launch an impeachment inquiry
even along the lines that are that are
weak the White House is also pointing
out some shortcomings in the way that
the Democrats are approaching this thing
legally they're pointing out the
Democrats have not actually voted as a
full house to open an impeachment
inquiry which would give them some
additional powers also they have not
really abided by precedent in terms of
using their subpoena power and allowing
the minority to subpoena witnesses as
well that part happens to be true the
question is whether the letter is an
overreach what the letter is designed to
do and whether the letter is setting the
groundwork for the possibility of a
full-scale stone wall by the Trump
administration now the reason that there
is suspicion that this may be setting
the precedent for a full-scale stone
wall no matter what Congress does is
because the Trump administration did
intervene over the past couple of days
and prevented Gordon Sunland president
Trump's ambassadors of the European
Union from testifying on Tuesday morning
before House committees House Democrats
that issued a subpoena to Gordon someone
in the impeachment inquiry he had bowed
to a State Department order to skip a
deposition
earlier in the day now Gordon Sunland as
you know is the as I say
Trump's ambassador to the EU he was on
that text message exchange with Kurt
Volker who is the special envoy to
Ukraine as well as with Bill Taylor who
happened to be the special replacement
for the ambassador to Ukraine
there on this text exchange all about
basically whether the Trump
administration was pressuring Ukraine to
prosecute Joe Biden in in order to
receive military aid and there was a
disagreement among these officials on
this text message exchange and so
sunland's testimony presumably would be
important in determining exactly what he
was told by the Trump White House the
Trump State Department stepped in and
they said we're not gonna let him
testify didn't really make clear under
what conditions this was Democrats had
requested that he testified now they've
issued a formal subpoena it presumably
could hold him in contempt they could
also hold the State Department in
contempt
Democrats have subpoenaed sunland for
his testimony and documents that day's
hair being withheld by the State
Department the subpoena demands those
documents be turned over by October 14th
and they say that Sunland must sit for a
deposition on October 16th before three
congressional panels which means before
the end of next week
the three Democrats who lead the various
committees that are that are doing this
investigation shift Cummings in angle
they said we consider this interference
to be obstruction of the impeachment
inquiry now they can consider whatever
they want to be obstruction it's not
obstruction until there's a court order
that says that you have to show up for
the subpoena under the conditions
specified by Congress and then the
person doesn't show up then you get into
obstruction of justice issues it is not
mere obstruction simply to say I'm not
showing up for a subpoena and then it
gets thrown into the court in fact that
sort of negotiation happens all the time
with regard to subpoenas somebody is
subpoenaed they say no it goes to court
the court rules but that's why it has to
be a formal subpoena that is the grounds
for the lawsuit itself the State
Department has not responded to requests
for comments at this point but President
Trump never one to shy away from Twitter
immediately went on Twitter and
explained why Sunland was not going to
be showing up he tweeted out I would
love to send ambassador Sunland a really
good man and great American to testify
but unfortunately he would be testifying
before a totally compromised kangaroo
court well Republicans rights have been
taken away and true facts are not
allowed out for the public to see
importantly ambassador someone's tweet
which few reports stated quote I believe
you are incorrect about president
Trump's intentions
the president has been crystal-clear no
quid pro quos of any kind that says it
all so he's happy with that particular
text message from Sunland that was to
Bill Taylor the replacement for the
ambassador to Ukraine and he doesn't
want someone testifying notice that he's
basically saying under no circumstances
do I want someone testifying not there's
gonna be a negotiation about what
documents are turned over and this is
what's leading to the grand suspicion on
the part of Democrats and on the part of
the media that the White House is going
to engage in an overall stonewalling
effort well that obviously was bolstered
by the letter that was sent by patched
Cipollone II who happens to be the who
happens to be the president's attorney
in this particular case he sends a
letter to Nancy Pelosi Engel Schiff and
Cummings and it's a fairly long letter
but it's worth going through simply
because there's so much controversy over
it and we tried to bring you the
information as always first and then we
make the judgment so here's what the
letter says quote I write on behalf of
President Donald J Trump in response to
your numerous legally unsupportable
demands made as part of what you have
labeled contrary to the Constitution of
the United States and all passed
bipartisan precedent as an impeachment
inquiry as you know you have designed
and implemented your inquiry in a manner
that violates fundamental fairness and
constitutionally mandated due process
well not yet not yet okay so to make a
due process claim you have to claim that
the process has not been due now
normally that usually arises at the
Senate the Senate criminal hearing part
of the process right there's the
impeachment inquiry that's the house
investigating and the house coming up
with whether they believe they should
impeach and then when you get to the
Senate there's an actual trial at the
trial there has to be a certain level of
due process presumably the Supreme Court
could step in and say due process has
not actually been followed here now
where he is right
Cybil Oney is that when he says that
there are certain things the Democrats
are doing that have never been done
before that is true and there are a
couple things specifically one they've
made clear that they are not going to
allow the minority to issue subpoenas
that is different to they keep claiming
this is an impeachment inquiry when they
have not actually voted in favor of an
impeachment inquiry basically they had
these ongoing investigations going in
the various committees Nancy Pelosi got
up and said impeachment inquiry and
everybody is now treating it like it's
an official act of Congress like
Congress is now undergoing
Pietschmann inquiry that's not true okay
actually have to vote for that in order
for there to be an official impeachment
inquiry for whatever that's worth okay
we can get to the rest of Sibyl oneis
letter in just one second first let's
talk about every time you head on over
to the post office so the post office is
a great place I mean they have all sorts
of great services but do you really want
to take all that crap you have to ship
and schlep it in the back of your car
there and then you wait in line and then
you have to just wait to get the parking
ticket out front which is what has
happened to me at least the last time I
went to the post office and that was the
last time I went to the post office
sounds like you know what I can do this
faster and easier naturally less
expensively by simply going to
stamps.com stamps.com brings all the
amazing services of the US postal office
directly to your computer whether you're
a small office sending invoices and
online sellers shipping out products or
even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day stamps comm can handle it
all with ease simply use your computer
to print official US postage 24/7 for
any letter any package and in class of
mail anywhere you want to send it once
your mail is ready you just hand it's
your mail carrier or you drop it in a
mailbox it is indeed that simple
stamps.com is a no-brainer it saves you
time it saves you money
it's no wonder over 700 thousand small
businesses use stamps calm before you
had to go down to the grocery store to
get stamps no longer head on over to
stamps calm right now and my listeners
get a special offer it includes a four
week trial plus free postage and the
digital scale and no long term
commitment just go to stamps com click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in Shapiro that is
stamps comm enter Shapiro and you get
that special deal and it's a pretty
spectacular deal stamps calm save time
money it's great go check it out right
now so I use it a daily where it's why I
personally use stamps calm okay so
simple loans letter continues he says
for example you have denied the
president the right to cross-examine
witnesses to call witnesses to receive
transcripts of testimony to have access
to evidence to have counsel present and
many other basic rights guaranteed to
all Americans well right now they're
just doing an investigation so it's not
clear that those rights actually
obtained right those rights would obtain
in a Senate trial but when it comes to
an impeachment inquiry that's just like
every other inquiry that happens on the
house level it's not clear that the
house can't set its own rules for
example simple Oni says you've conducted
your proceedings in secret you have
violated civil liberties and the
separation of powers by threatening
executive branch officials claiming you
will seek to punish those who exercise
fundamental constitutional rights and
prerogatives ok now that last part where
basically they've threatened to hold
people in contempt for not obeying their
requests those are empty threats that's
not a violation of the Constitution that
is them being legally idiotic and
attempting to push a false narrative
which is that if you negotiate with them
over the terms of your testimony that
you are somehow going to be held in
contempt that is not something that they
actually have the power to do in order
to have a contempt holding you have to
first issue a legally binding subpoena
for example never before in our history
has the House of Representatives under
the control of either political party
taken the American people down the
dangerous path you seem determined to
pursue this letter has written more as a
political document obviously than it is
as a legal document simple Oni says put
simply you seek to overturn the results
of the 2016 election and deprive the
American people of the president they
have freely chosen many Democrats now
apparently view impeachment not only as
a means to undo the Democratic results
of the last election but as a strategy
to influence in the next election which
is barely more than a year away as one
member of Congress explained he is
concerned that if we don't impeach the
president he will get reelected that be
representative Al Green on MSNBC they're
highly partisan and unconstitutional
effort threatens grave and lasting
damage to our democratic institutions so
our systems of free elections into the
American people it's a fine perfectly
fine political argument completely has
nothing to do with legality right just
from a legal standpoint this is not part
of legal document this is a political
argument an argument with which I
generally agree by the way but a
political argument nonetheless Cibolo
knees the lawyer he says for his part
president Trump's at the unprecedented
step of providing the public
transparency by declassifying
and releasing the record of his call
with zolensky of Ukraine and then it
says the record clearly established the
call was completely appropriate and that
there is no basis for your inquiry the
fact there was nothing wrong with the
call was also powerfully confirmed by
Chairman chief's decision to create a
false version of the call and read it to
the American people at a congressional
hearing without disclosing that he was
simply making it all up now again shift
made a fool of himself
right but I don't really think that that
is what Schiff was do I mean to be I'm
trying to be fair to everybody here
because the fact is that well I think
that Schiff is a real snake in the grass
when it comes to his proceedings I think
that the the pretended outrage at him
faking a conversation in a clearly
made-up way and pretending that
everybody thought that was real I don't
really buy that particular line of
argument in addition information has
recently come to Lex
Saloni that the whistleblower had
contacted chairmanships office before
filing the complaint that of course is
true for these reasons president Trump
and his administration reject or
baseless unconstitutional efforts to
overturn the democratic process your
unprecedented actions have left the
president with no choice in order to
fulfill his duties to the American
people the Constitution the executive
branch and all future occupants of the
office of the presidency President Trump
and his administration cannot
participate in your partisan and
unconstitutional inquiry under these
circumstances okay the key phrase there
is under these circumstances because if
those circumstances can be rectified
if the house votes for an impeachment
inquiry if the house allows minority
rights to the minority party then will
the Trump administration cooperate if so
the letters fine if not the letter is
gonna run up very quickly in to the
Democrats and maybe some Republican
members of the house suggesting that the
Trump administration is engaging in at
least a cover-up and what could be a
constitutional crisis a constitutional
crisis as Noah Feldman law professor at
Harvard correctly suggests a
constitutional crisis is where the
branches go up against one another and
there is no clear solution as to what
happens next so the legislative branch
subpoenas everybody in the executive
branch the executive branch instead of
turning down some accepting others and
going through the court simply says no
under no circumstances are we going to
cooperate under any circumstance is
offended enough by the executive the
house could impeach the executive okay
so is this letter actually a blanket
attempt to say we're not participating
under any circumstances or is it a
conditional letter is the letter saying
listen under the current circumstances
where you are clearly manipulating the
process true under these circumstances
where you're clearly being partisan
hacks who have no interest in a fair
process find it true if under these
circumstances where you pretend you have
an impeachment inquiry and the house
hasn't even voted for one which is true
we're not going to participate that at
least is part of a negotiation if it's
just listen we don't like the basis for
the inquiry we think the basis for the
inquiry is wrong so no that is a
constitutional crisis and that is not
going to end well for the Trump
administration okay so the letter
continues they say your inquiry is
constitutionally invalid and violates
basic due process rights and thus f
operation of powers so they say that in
the history of our nation the House of
Representatives has never attempted to
launch an impeachment inquiry against
the president without a majority of the
house taking political accountability
for that decision by voting to authorize
such a dramatic constitutional step
that's not really true in the Andrew
Johnson impeachment I don't believe the
house actually formally voted to open
impeachment inquiry they just voted for
impeachment here House leadership claims
to have initiated the gravest
interbranch conflicts contemplated our
Constitution by means of nothing more
than a press conference at which the
Speaker of the House simply announced an
official impeachment inquiry their
contracts process is unprecedented okay
that part is true that part is true the
of the committees inquiry also
suffers from a separate fatal defect
despite speaker Pelosi's commitment to
treat the president with fairness the
committees have not established any
procedures affording the president even
the most basic protections demanded by
due process under the Constitution and
by fundamental fairness now the house
does have unilateral power over how the
impeachment inquiry is run it is a
separate branch of government it does
not have to actually engage in the sorts
of in the sorts of negotiation with the
White House that the White House is
claiming that it has to so this part I
don't really see the legal basis for the
house has sole power over how it sets up
the impeachment inquiry again they can
vote for impeach without an inquiry they
could vote from Pietschmann today so
they don't actually have to have
quote-unquote due process it's at the
Senate trial that presumably you have to
have some form of due process they say
these due process rights are not a
matter of discretion for the committees
to dispense with the will to the
contrary there are constitutional
requirements the Supreme Court has
recognized the due process protections
apply to all congressional
investigations well it's not quite as
simple as that the cases that they are
citing are not quite on point indeed it
has been recognized that the due process
clause applies to impeachment
proceedings yes in the Senate in the
Senate the right to cross-examine
witnesses call witnesses present
evidence dates back 150 years again in
the Senate that seems to be more true
than in the house now they may be right
that the president shouldn't be treated
unfairly this way and they may be right
that the Democrats should simply allow
some of this stuff to happen but is this
a blanket Stonewall or is it conditional
again that is the big question here and
it's not quite clear from this letter
they say so we comply with
Constitution's demands appropriate
procedures would include at a minimum
the right to see all evidence to present
evidence to
witnesses to have counsel present that
all hearings to cross-examine all
witnesses to make objections relating to
examination of witnesses or the
admissible 'ti of testimony and evidence
and to respond to evidence and testimony
okay again this is that all makes sense
at a trial it doesn't make sense in the
context of a house of a house inquiry so
as I say the legal basis for this letter
are fairly weak fairly weak and then
they talk about the Congress resorting
to threats and intimidation against
executive branch witnesses again that is
inappropriate that does not fatally mean
that there can't be an impeachment
inquiry or that the White House can
ignore all subpoenas for example then
the letter gets into basically a
political argument saying that the
impeachment inquiry is seeking to
reverse the election of 2016 and
influence the election of 2020 again a
political argument with which I agree
but has virtually nothing to do with
legality when they say there's no
legitimate basis for the impeachment
inquiry
so that again suggests that no matter
what Congress does they are not going to
cooperate because they find the basis
not legit well if that were the case
Nixon could have just stonewalled all
right here to just have listen I find
this whole thing non legit you've been
Al Pacino and in justice for all you're
out of water this entire Court is out of
order yeah that doesn't work that
doesn't work in actual legal proceedings
the letter concludes for the foregoing
reasons the president cannot allow your
constitutionally illegitimate
proceedings to distract him and those in
the executive branch from their work on
behalf of the American people the
president has a country to lead the
American people elected him to do this
job
he remains focused on fulfilling his
promises to the American people etc etc
etc they say we hope that in light of
the many deficiencies we have identified
in your proceedings you will abandon the
current and valid efforts to pursue an
impeachment inquiry and join the
president and focusing on the goals that
matter to the American people okay so
does this mean that this is a full-scale
stone wall answer we don't know yet we
don't know yet if it turns into a
full-scale stone wall this is not gonna
go great for the Trump administration
it's not if it's just a political ploy
by Cipollone II and Trump if it's just
we want these things and if you give us
those things we'll cooperate then all
right that's not bad but if this turns
into we're not cooperating with Congress
I still believe in the Constitution the
Congress does have the power of inquiry
if this were Barack Obama's saying I'm
not gonna cooperate under any
circumstances because I deny your power
to investigate that would be a
constitutional violation the Supreme
Court is likely to
that way it's not gonna go the way Trump
thinks if this is a pure full-on stone
again we don't know whether it is or not
because the letter is not clear on that
okay in just a second we're going to
talk a little bit more about this
whistleblower because now it turns out
that there are some serious questions
about the nature identity of the
whistleblower and the whistleblowers
report we'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about why you
need a great suit so you think that you
are going to be able to just go down to
the local the the local big-box store
and buy yourself a suit off the rack
that looks pretty good the problem is
that your body was not made off the rack
and so the suit looks terrible on you
I'm just gonna be frank with you that
suit that you are wearing right now it
hangs off of you like drapes and this is
why you should have a tailored suit you
should look like James Bond and you can
do this without spending an arm and a
leg head on over to Indo Chino comm Indo
Chino is the world's largest
made-to-measure menswear brand they make
suits shirts coats and more everything
has made your exact measurements for a
great fit you get to personalize all the
details including lapel lining and your
own monogram Indo Chino has hundreds of
suit options for all occasions including
work formal events even your own wedding
the best part is they're affordable
almost all of their custom clothing is
under $400 the process is simple choose
your fabric picker customizations submit
your measurements your package will be
delivered straight to your door in two
weeks you can get measured and design
your suit at your nearest enjoyed Chino
showroom I've done that myself it's
awesome it's really close actually a fun
day out or do it all yourself online in
Indo Chino comm it's a great suit it
really is start your style upgrade now
with 30 bucks off your total purchase of
399 bucks or more at endowed Chino comm
when you enter Shapiro's at checkout
plus shipping is free that's Indo Chino
com promo code Shapiro for 30 bucks off
your total purchase of 399 bucks or more
it's an incredible deal for
made-to-measure
clothing you really have no excuse to
wear clothing that doesn't fit go check
out Indo Chino comm they really are
first-rate ok so meanwhile there is some
news about the whistle blower that
should be disquieting because as I have
said several things can be true at once
as I'm fined of saying one bad idea for
the Trump administration to completely
Stonewall the investigation it has not
ended well for Clinton it didn't end
well for Nixon it's just not a smart
strategy to this can be a highly
partisan inquiry that obviously smacks
of an attempt to take down Trump without
proper evidence I mean that that so far
seems to be the case
three it can turn out the whistleblower
was manipulating things from the inside
with the help of Adam Schiff from the
outside it now seems that there are some
news about the whistleblower this would
explain why the Democrats excuse me have
been so eager to prevent the identity of
the whistleblower from becoming known
according to byron york reporting for
the washington examiner the
whistleblower apparently not only has
political bias but the political bias is
that the whistleblower apparently
according to the Inspector General of
the intelligence community had a
professional relationship with one of
the Democratic candidates okay that is
not good news right for the Democrats
according to a person with with
knowledge to what Atkinson said was that
the whistleblower self disclosed that he
was registered Democrat and that he had
a prior working relationship with a
current twenty twenty Democratic
presidential candidate apparently the
Inspector General did not identify the
Democratic candidate with whom the
whistleblower had a connection it's
unclear what the working or professional
relationship between the two was now I'm
gonna go out on a limb here and do some
rank speculation could be completely
wrong I'm gonna say it's probably Joe
Biden I'm gonna say that probably what
happened here is that this whistleblower
had a relationship with Joe Biden we
know he was in the White House working
on Ukraine issues so is it possible that
this whistleblower had a relationship
with Joe Biden knew the situation in
Ukraine and when Joe Biden's name got
brought up in the context of Ukraine
immediately jumped to the conclusion
that there was an investigation into Joe
Biden that was the basis of all of this
and he wasn't gonna have that because he
knows Joe Biden and Joe Biden is a good
man that is it that seems quite possible
it seems quit and if so that certainly
colors the whistleblowers memos the
original whistleblower memo that
apparently raised hackles is now being
reported by CBS News CBS News has
learned the full contents of what
appears to be a memo written by the
whistleblower one day after President
Trump spoke with ukrainian President
Vladimir zalenski in July the memo dated
July 26 is based on a conversation the
whistleblower had with an unnamed White
House official who listened to the calls
again leakiest White House of all time
apparently according to the memo the
White House official described the
contents of the call as crazy
frightening and completely lacking in
substance related to national security
the whistleblower said the official was
visibly shaken by what had transpired
and seemed keen to inform a trusted
colleague within the US national
security apparatus about to call okay
what made him call this guy
we'll call this guy is it possible that
person on the call his friend from the
White House is a White House staffer
who's a holdover from the Obama
administration was friendly with team
Biden called up another person who was
friendly with team Biden and that person
filed a whistleblower complaint again
rank speculation could be completely
wrong I'm gonna guess that is not
completely wrong so I'm sure we will
find out more in the future if that
turns out to be the case then it
certainly casts a lot of doubt on the
motives of the whistleblower now does
that mean that Trump is innocent of all
manipulation you can't we've read the
transcript right we've seen text
messages there will be additional
evidence presented but it does make this
look a lot more like a partisan hit on
behalf of Joe Biden than it does like an
attempt to root out and ferret out
corruption inside the White House now
one thing is pretty clear a lot of the
diplomats who are involved in the
Ukraine situation where at the very
least is quieted by the activity in the
Trump administration from that text
message conversation between kurt volker
the special envoy to the Ukraine and
Bill Taylor who is the interim
ambassador to Ukraine and Gordon sunland
who is the EU ambassador there's
obviously a lot of disquiet about this
and now their reports from the New York
Times that members of the State
Department were were at least a little
perturbed about the way in which aid to
Ukraine was restored
Brad Frieden who is the State
Department's acting deputy assistant
secretary overseeing issues in Europe
and Eurasia apparently wrote in a
September 12th email the day after the
restoration of Ukrainian aid quote keep
moving people nothing to see here it's
just which is never a wonderful thing to
write in an email exchange where people
are worried
he said the National Security Council
would not publicly announced that 141
million dollars in state Department
assistance was being restored after
being held up in what the White House
described as a normal review which is
weird by the way I will say it is weird
right it's weird to say that you went
through a normal review process and then
you greenlit the aid but we're not going
to announce it publicly and that like
why why why the attempt to keep quiet
according to one of these emails which
is presumably to Bill Taylor it says in
terms of public messaging the National
Security Council is deliberately
treating both the hold and its lifting
as administrative matters there won't be
a public announcement on the Sun my
advice is to keep your public messaging
low-key as well along the lines of OMB
has completed its administrative review
of security assistance for Ukraine
and our assistants will continue as
before which again starts to look at
least a little bit suspicious so more
details I'm sure will be forthcoming as
always because we're at the beginning of
this process not at the end of this
process and lots of things can be true
at once Democrats can be manipulating
the process they can be being unfair to
President Trump this could have been
pushed by a partisan whistle blower and
it could be that there is malfeasance
inside the Trump White House all of
those things could be possible at once
we're gonna keep an eye on it and again
I'm one of these people who is fond of
the phrase I don't know
you know I'm fond of that phrase you
know you should be fond of that phrase
too because you don't know the only
people who know what actually happened
in this whole policy situation our Trump
and his immediate aides those are the
only people who know okay so if you are
suggesting that you know full-scale
Trump is totally honest and everything
is totally aboveboard and fine you don't
know that if you're a Democrat and
you're suggesting that you know for a
fact that Trump was only out to get by
and you certainly don't know that based
on the available evidence at this point
we're gonna find out and the
stonewalling is actually more of a
danger to Trump's future as precedent
then is the inquiry itself I feel this
like this the same way that I do about
the the Muller inquiry right during
Muller there are a lot of people on the
right we're urging from fire Muller and
the investigation just stop this thing
then I kept saying no let it go let go
all the way out because in the end
Muller is likely to find nothing and if
you stop it then it starts to look like
obstruction and starts to look like
you're afraid of what Muller is going to
find well the same thing holds true here
don't stop the investigation listen the
Democrats are gonna blow this thing
anyway so you may as well give them
enough rope to hang themselves because
they certainly won't hang themselves
almost no matter what you do okay in
just a second we're gonna get to the
situation in Turkey which has become
quite grave quite quickly because it
turns out when the President of the
United States signals to a dictatorial
foreign power then go in and murder a
bunch of people who helped us out
fighting Isis guess what the Turks move
we'll get into that in just one second
first let's talk about credit card debt
it's very easy to rack up credit card
debt you know like you make a couple bad
decisions all of a sudden you're paying
20% interest rates every single month
and you're stuck in credit card debt
forever and it's hard to get out well
this is why you may need to check out
Lending Club calm with Lending Club
consolidate your debt or pay off your
credit cards with one fixed monthly
payment Lending Club has helped millions
of people regain control of their
finances with affordable fixed-rate
personal loans no trips to a bank no
high interest credit cards just go to
Lending Club com tell them about
yourself and how much you want to borrow
pick the terms that are right for you
if you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
accounts in as little as a few days
Lending Club is the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform over
thirty five billion dollars in loans
issued it's really easy to get into debt
instead of you know fussing and being
upset about how you got into instead
solve the problem you know focus on
solving the problem that's where Lending
Club comes in Lending Club dot-com / Ben
check your rate in minutes borrow up to
40 grand
that's Lending Club com / been lending
club at comm / Ben go check them out
right now almonds made by web bank
member FDIC Equal Housing lender get the
problem solved Lending Club accom / Ben
alrighty we'll get to more of that in
just a second but you're actually gonna
have to go over to Daley wire.com in
order to subscribe to see the rest of
the show today plus when you subscribe
you get all sorts of goodies not only do
you get the greatest of all Everage
vessels of course but you also get
special access to our Sunday special ray
get that on Saturday and you get all of
the material behind the paywall this
week's Sunday special is Neil deGrasse
Tyson it was a blast there's an academic
I care that I'd learn something every
day if a day goes by I don't learn
something that's a wasted day and
ideally you should get your mind blown
at least once a week by just something
whoa I never knew that and so for me
that is how I establish and derive
meaning in my life
the conversation really is fascinating
it gets spicy we go deep it's really
it's really a great conversation you're
gonna want to see it for Shore so go
check that out over at se Lee Weyer also
note the daily wires long-awaited app is
finally here and it really is first-rate
if you're a subscriber you can access
all of our content including articles
shows and more straight from the app
including the Sunday special all access
subscribers also get our new and
exclusive discussion features or you can
interact directly with people like me
and are their hosts like why would you
want to interact directly with knowles
but I guess you can writers other
special guests you can interact directly
with us I mean all sorts of awesome
stuff we are constantly upgrading that
user experience the app is available on
Apple and Android so download it today
become a subscriber come join the fun go
subscribe over daily wire.com where the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
hey meanwhile it's been a very bad week
for president Trump overall and this
situation with Turkey is not making
things any better Trump signaled that he
was withdrawing some 50 US troops not he
said he was withdrawing them from Syria
altogether that's not true he's
apparently just withdrawing them from
the area where Turkey wants to invade
and kill a bunch of Kurds and that is
foolhardy at best and now you're hearing
a lot of arguments today from people
including President Trump we can't be
part of these forever Wars forever Wars
for everyone this wasn't a forever war
there's 50 troops in one place and
here's the thing there's very there were
a few things that are certain in
American foreign policy one thing that
is absolutely certain in American
foreign policy where American boots
disappear things get worse and when
American troops are present things are
not as bad when you remove American
troops things get worse so the question
becomes not how many lives are you going
to sacrifice for the Kurds but how many
Kurdish lives are you willing to
sacrifice so that our soldiers don't
have to stand in this particular place
because you know how many American
soldiers were killed by the Turks over
the past several years the answer is
zero the answer is right you know why
cuz the Turks don't want to go to war
with us man there's this like there's
this bizarre notion on the isolationist
sort of Pat Buchanan right Tucker
Carlson sometimes says stuff like this
where he'll say why should our boys die
for xx being a foreign country well
that's not the question the question is
why shouldn't we stand there so that
people don't attack that foreign country
and that's not true in every
circumstance you have to calculate the
risk and you have to calculate the
threat I mean there's certain places
where if you put troops that is
basically an invitation for an attack on
American troops and there are other
places where if you put troops you know
full-scale the Turks are not going to go
into this area because if they kill an
American troop we are going to then
proceed to devastate their economy for
example so pulling out of that area
is actually an invitation to escalation
of war and more than that when you pull
out like I'm always enough to remember
when Republicans understood that Barack
Obama pulling out of Iraq led to the
rise of Isis in the first place and now
Donald Trump is saying why don't just
pull out of this area where they're
holding like fifteen to twenty thousand
Isis soldiers will pull out of that area
the Kurds who are defending those Isis
prisons are going to be under attack by
the Turks do you really think the Turks
are going to go in there and stomp out
Isis they didn't before
the fact is that the Turks kind of have
an interest in Isis being there it gives
them an excuse
and kill as many members of the PKK the
sort of communist Kurdish party
insurgency and by the way non PKK
members right just Kurdish nationalists
who don't want to be murdered by Isis
they it gives the Turks an excuse to go
into Syria in the first place because
Bashar Assad an excuse to go after
Syrian dissidents it gives Iran an
excuse to be in the region this was the
problem with Isis the reason Isis was
able to follow was able to fester and
become a huge problem is because nobody
in the region except for maybe the Kurds
actually had an interest in killing the
members of Isis and that's why the
United States had to go in it's not like
we pull out now everybody takes care of
their own business we were in there
because people weren't taking care of
their own business or because they're
interested in align with ours in this
particular part of the world so
President Trump is making what I think
is a deeply empty argument when he's
like well we have to just put we're
ending wars ending wars you know he used
to say that I'm old enough to remember
Barack Obama right this was his thing
I'm a number war in Afghanistan I'm in
the war in Iraq yeah it turns out that
sometimes you ending the war means
another war gets started and we have our
troops back in there in five seconds
which is exactly what happened in Iraq
right
Obama pulls out the troops Isis rises
guess who has to go back in you know it
would have helped not pulling out the
troops and when you are talking about a
very low level of troop presence and
pretty much zero risk from the Turks
toward American troops do not follow the
BS arguments that the Turks were gonna
go in and start wiping out American
troops alongside the Kurds that is not a
thing that was going to happen anyway
President Trump tweeted out that he had
moved some 50 troops he tweeted out
fighting between various groups that has
been going on for hundreds of years
USA should never have been in Middle
East moved our fifty soldiers out turkey
must take over captured Isis fighters
that Europe refused to have returned the
stupid endless wars for us are ending ok
well I thought that you were championing
the fact that we defeated Isis so which
we you've just left them there like
really if the argument is we should
never have been there
one of them signal achievements is
destroying Isis stand is destroying at
the Caliphate but now he's arguing we
should never have been there in the
first place ok well we weren't in
Afghanistan and then Afghanistan turned
over to the Taliban and then we got 9/11
so it turns out then we don't fight
terrorists overseas
sometimes they come here and then they
kill us and Isis was doing
on a fairly regular basis in the this is
this is what we call the ultimate straw
man argument from President Trump you
know the Lindsey Graham rightly went
after Trump over all of this he says
that Trump shamelessly abandoned them
which is strong language from Lindsey
Graham who's been a very very strong
ally of President Trump throughout his
presidency Graham said pray for our
Kurdish allies who have been shamelessly
abandoned by the Trump administration
this move ensures the re-emergence of
Isis fair fair and there's really no
rationale for it other than Trump
probably got somebody in his ear saying
keep the campaign promise pull out the
troops Barack Obama did the exact same
thing Turkey by the way immediately
moved within 24 hours to start killing
as many cards as humanly possible
according to the Washington Post
Turkey's government launched a long
expected offensive into northeastern
Syria on Wednesday with airstrikes and
shelling targeting Syrian Kurdish
fighters who have played a central role
in aiding the us-led battle against the
Islamic state militant group the
operation with some ground forces
crossing the border later came just days
after President Trump's a startling
announcement that the United States
would not stand in Turkey's way bringing
sharp rebukes from even the president's
Republican allies the Turkish for a
threatened to further fracture a war
shattered Syria as ayan Cara the capital
of Turkey moved to create a safe zone
after failing to agree on its size and
nature during negotiations with the
United States Turkey's goals to push the
Syrian Kurds considered enemies by
turkey from the border region and
apparently civilians are already being
killed in this foray now one of the
arguments that Trump put out today he
said well what have the Kurds ever done
for us he says well you know they've
only been defending their own sovereign
territory they weren't there at Normandy
right they weren't there in other
foreign wars yeah well here's the
reality most nations have not been I
mean in World War two we went to help
the Brits in World War one we went to
help the Brits when was the last time
the Brits had helped us in a war that
wasn't a thing okay the fact is that
sometimes US interests are involved the
u.s. does have an interest in preventing
the rise of Isis again do we not the
u.s. does have an interest in ensuring
that American allies are not abandoned
especially when the cost is minimal I
mean we're not talking about sacrificing
thousands of troops for the freedom of
the Kurds that would be a legit argument
about whether we should do that anything
a strong argument made that we shouldn't
but if you're talking about sacrificing
no troops just to have people standing
there so the Turks don't go in and
murder
thousands of people it seems like a
pretty strong argument to leave the
troops there
Sergio Gore who is the he's one of the
press people for Rand Paul who's an
isolationist he says expected that some
in the GOP who took us into these
endless Quagmire's in the middle east
are unhappy about ending wars but where
is the left
the silence is resounding silence is not
always golden Donald Trump is doing the
right thing and should have bipartisan
support I know Sergio Sergio's wrong on
this president Trump's is true should
have never been there in the first place
again should have never been where in
the first place
like I don't know what the first place
means are we talking about like going
all the way back to the time of TE
Lawrence it turns out the West has been
present in the Middle East for quite a
long time and again we weren't really
present in Afghanistan after the late
1980s it did not renowned to our benefit
particularly so and bad policy from
President Trump meanwhile the 2020 race
is getting weird
Hillary Clinton is popping up her head
again this all happened because Hillary
Clinton did an interview with Judy
Woodruff
in which she explained that if she ran
should be President Trump again of
course she won the popular vote but she
did not be President Trump which is why
she's not sitting in the Oval Office
right now so he'll here is Hillary
Clinton explaining that yes she could be
Trump again I'm sure by the way the
polls do not show this it truly is
remarkable how obsessed he remains with
me but this latest tweet is you know so
typical of him nothing has been more
examined and looked at than my emails we
all know that so he's either lying or
delusional or both there was no subpoena
as he says in a tweet this morning and
so maybe there does need to be a rematch
I mean obviously I can beat him again
okay and then apparently she tried to
claim that she was joking but when
Hillary loved to get back in no doubt no
doubt she would and the Democratic field
is extraordinarily weak Trump tweeted at
Hillary of course because he can't
resist he he he loves the fact that he
as do we all
he said I think the crook the crooked
Hillary Clinton should enter the race
and try and steal it away from uber left
Elizabeth Warren only one condition the
crooked one must explain all of her high
crime scenes to be here including how
and why she deleted 30,000 emails after
getting C subpoenas he would be
congressional subpoena I do love that he
calls her the crooked one the crooked
one and then Hillary Clinton's tweeted
back don't
me do your job uh-huh man Hillary
Clinton jumping back in finally might
make this thing fun again meanwhile Joe
Biden is out there suggesting the Trump
should be impeached this of course
because one thing is true Joe Biden
certainly does not want his son his on
contact in Ukraine made the center of
attention again here is it Joe Biden
going after Trump with his words and his
actions President Trump has indicted
himself by obstructing justice refusing
to comply with the congressional inquiry
he's already convicted himself in full
view of the world and the American
people
Donald Trump has violated his oath of
office betrayed this nation and
committed impeachable acts to preserve
our Constitution our democracy our basic
integrity he should be impeached okay he
still has not actually explained on what
basis when he says obstruction not yet
not maybe maybe that'll happen but not
yet as we've been discussing all day by
the way I do love that Joe Biden
continues to engage in this myth making
about how there were no scandals in the
Obama administration there's another
line that Joe Biden dropped yesterday he
said that one of the things he's proud
of is that there were no scandals yeah I
was there there were lots of them dude
okay Peter Schweitzer has a piece in The
New York Times today the the Biden
campaign is super pissed off about it
the piece is called what hunter Biden
did was legal and that's the problem
and Peter Schweitzer who has written a
bunch of books about corruption inside
Washington is he really a terrific
researcher he he suggests that the
Washington corrupt practices act as
necessary to stop political families
from self dealing he says his Vice
President Joe Biden's served his point
person on American policy toward China
and Ukraine in both instances his son
hunter a businessman landed deals he was
apparently unqualified to score save for
one thing his father and then he
ascribed the fact that in December 2013
Joe and Hunter Biden flew aboard Air
Force two to China less than two weeks
after the trip hunters from Rosemont
Seneca Partners which he founded with
two other businessmen in June 2013
finalized a deal to open a fund BH our
partners thus far the firm has invested
about 2.1 billion dollars according to
its website in trying to disprove a link
between the father's powerful position
and the son surprising success hunter
Biden's lawyers claimed he didn't take
an equity stake in BH our partners until
after by the left office but he took a
board seat when it was founded in
December 2013 at the same time his
business partner was a vice chairman
with the Russian invasion of Crimea in
Joe Biden became point person in Ukraine
- that same year hunter Biden landed a
board position with the Ukrainian energy
giant Purisima Holdings despite having
no background in energy or Ukraine he
was paid as much as $50,000 a month
according to financial records
why would someone with Moe so little
experience be able to command such
enormous payments was pretty obvious his
daddy was Joe Biden right so when he
says no scandals what he really means is
please don't investigate me please
please don't investigate me and as it
turns out the other Democrats are going
to have some problems too so I came out
just a couple of days ago that Elizabeth
Warren apparently has been issuing
statements that are not consistent about
why she was fired in 1971 from a job as
a teacher it turns out she was not fired
she said she was fired because she was
pregnant it turns out not so much here's
the clip in 2007 in which Warren herself
basically acknowledges that she left the
job voluntarily I worked it was in a
public school system but I worked with
the the children with disabilities and I
did that for a year
and then that summer I actually didn't
have the education courses so I was on
an emergency certificate it was called
and I went back to graduate school and
took a couple of courses in education
and said I don't think this is going to
work out for me okay I don't think this
is gonna work out for me now she's been
claiming simultaneously that she was
actually let go because she was pregnant
I am woman hear me be victimized is her
sort of campaign point now she's sort of
sticking with the story it doesn't
matter that the records show that she
resigned it doesn't matter that they
offered unanimously to extend war in a
second year contract with that emergency
certificate in place she's still gonna
stick with this story because she has to
keep pretending she's a victim this sort
of stuff will come back to bite
Elizabeth Warren directly in the ass
right this is exactly what she did with
the Pocahontas nonsense she's trying to
claim a mantle of victimhood because she
needs it in the Democratic primaries but
she's putting herself in for a world of
hurt because if she's lying about
victimology she's had a pretty
privileged life in the United States if
she's lying about victimology that is
not something that's gonna read down to
her benefit she's sticking by her story
however here's Elizabeth Warren
yesterday saying that no no no no after
all she was fired because she was
pregnant when I was first hired I didn't
have all of the right courses for a
permanent certificate but I was hired so
it was called an emergency certificate
of one year but I'd already been removed
they gave me the job and said you're
hired for the next year it's yours kid
and when they discovered I was pregnant
they said oops it doesn't matter much
what the term is but let's be clear I
was six months pregnant uh it was my
first job I was 22 years old and the job
that was mine that I'd been hired for
for the next year was taken away when
they knew I was pregnant okay there is
no evidence for this there's no evidence
for this other than her own account
again the actual documents according to
the Washington free beacon suggest that
she was she resigned and that her
resignation was accepted with regret so
I'm sure this will not be the end of
that particular investigation for
Elizabeth Warren nonetheless she is the
front-runner and she is not stacking up
all that well against Prez
and Trump by poll data so we'll see how
all of this works for her as time it
goes on okay time for a quick thing I
like and then a thing that I hate so
things that I like today let's do let's
do another movie that I had to watch on
my 13 hour journey to Israel so they had
a lot of movies that were available for
viewing one of these was the movie
yesterday and this is a pretty charming
movie by Danny Boyle
the basic premise of the movie is that
there is a guy who is sort of a pub
singer and he's completely unsuccessful
and then there is basically a major
power outage when the power goes back on
all over the world a bunch of things are
missing from everybody's memory
including the Beatles The Beatles just
don't exist so nobody actually is aware
of the Beatles music except for this guy
this guy somehow knows the Beatles music
and so he starts playing their songs and
becomes of course a rock legend here's a
little bit of the trailer this is my
last gig if I was a four by now it's
like a miracle
[Music]
what happened electricity flicked off
all over the world
yesterday Ellie bought you a present all
my troubles seemed so far away now it
looks as though they're to say I didn't
want it Paul McCartney wrote at the
Beatles who and the movie is is quite
charming now I will freely admit I am
NOT a Beatles fan I've said before I
think they're the most overrated band in
history they could write a hook I mean
there's no question they could write a
hook but the movie is cute and does show
sort of the power of music and there's
sort of moving moment at the end where
you discover that the world is somehow
in some ways better because the Beatles
music was was brought about later in
time ins it's it's sort of an
interesting flick and the premise of it
is is interesting as well at the very
least it's fun and charming go check it
out yesterday by the director of Slumdog
Millionaire okay time for a quick thing
that I hate okay so over Yom Kippur
there were a bevy of anti-semitic
incidents as we have become it used to
so in the United States there was
apparently a fire set on the grounds of
a synagogue in Brooklyn which has become
sort of wrote frankly and we've seen a
bunch of these sorts of attacks in New
York this Brooklyn synagogue was
apparently again somebody set a fire
right there on the on the front steps
during Yom Kippur according to the
police
New York City has seen a massive surge
in hate crimes many of them have been
targeting Jews also over Yom Kippur
there was an attack on a show in Germany
the attack on the show in Germany was by
a white supremacist who live-streamed
this thing on Amazon it was hideous
obviously according to the UK Daily Mail
a gunman the German synagogue ranted
about feminism immigration in the
Holocaust before he shot two people dead
in a livestream dances medic rampage on
Judaism's holiest day the shooter killed
a man or woman threw a grenade into
Jewish cemetery and left explosives near
the synagogue in hell after failing to
force his way inside while worshipers
prayed on Yom Kippur the suspect named
by billed as a 20-cent named terrorists
and I don't name mass shooters he was
not to glorify them he was later
arrested after trying to flee in a taxi
according to German media the German
government offered deep sympathy and
said it was an anti-semitic attack
possibly motivated by right-wing
extremism he was wearing military
fatigues in a helmet camera and he shot
a woman dead in the street after she
confronted him outside the synagogue for
about 80 people or praying now I happen
to be in Israel right now and I will
just note that many of the same people
who claim that Israel is the rationale
for anti-semitism the reason people hate
Jews is because of Israel because Israel
so cruel and terrible and because of how
they treat the Palestinians and all of
us these are the same people or if
Israel didn't exist they would still be
shooting Jews there would just be no
place for Jews to go the fact is that
thousands of Jews every year are leaving
Europe and good for them because Europe
is becoming a hellhole for Jews
everybody knows this hey The Wall Street
Journal has reported on it the United
Times has reported on it it is not safe
for Jews in places like France it is
increasingly not safe for Jews in places
like Sweden places like Germany places
like Great Britain people are leaving on
mass in the place they're going is to
the State of Israel because the State of
Israel is still a safe haven for the
Jewish people and the same people more
claiming that it's only Israel's
presence that is causing anti-semitism
seem to forget that Jews were killed in
the millions when Israel didn't exist
specifically because no country would
take in the Jews and because the Jews
had no place to go the British Empire
was banning the Jews from entering the
nascent State of Israel before it was
the State of Israel from entering
British Palestine during the actual
Holocaust itself and so for all the talk
about why Israel was bad why it
shouldn't exist why Israel is terrible
and horrible and all this the reason
that Israel exists is because of stuff
like this okay it's because Jews have
been the victims of anti-semitism will
continue to be the victims of
anti-semitism and so long as people keep
maintaining the absolute stupid fiction
that if Israel didn't exist everybody
would be nice to that you know how
historically ignorant you'd have to be
to actually believe this that if Israel
didn't exist everyone would be nice to
the Jews within living memory 3/4 of the
Jewish population on planet earth was
slaughtered so I'm gonna go no on that
I'm gonna go no and the State of Israel
wasn't there then it's a no on that it's
just it's its absurdity at the high
level israel is not the cause of
anti-semitism israel is a place where
people are fleeing anti-semitism and
that continues to be the truth certainly
in Europe okay we'll be back here later
today with two additional hours of
content a lot more news that will be
breaking I'm sure I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show the Ben Shapiro
show is produced by Robert Sterling
directed by Mike joiner executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens assistant director
Pavo wide outski edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena
hair and makeup is by Jessica alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew cliff
[Music]